hi again um i'm going to make a tutorial
today well not a tutorial but a review
on a program i'm using called
ccleaner
this is uh this is what it looks like
a little pair there it tells you specs
yeah you can look at it um
first i will show you where to get it
open your internet browser
uh happy with safari you can use any
um or others and type in just see
cleaner
the first result will be ccleaner.com
you can also get this from
like download.com or techradar any of
these sites filehippo
just don't torrent it it's free software
anyway
um
click for a quick tour and click here to
download ccleaner
um you can read about it it's
daycleaner.com
um
so download it there and when you do
install it the instructions are
extremely simple
you will have
it'll probably give you a
little thing on your top or you can just
go to your menu and type in ccleaner to
run it for the first time comes up
click on it then usd comes up of course
and
ccleaner
what it does
um it's exactly what it says it cleans
your c drive it um it removes temporary
internet files i haven't run it in a few
minutes and it's really going to pick up
a few megabytes
it'll remove your
your cachet like recently uh used
documents so if you go into here recent
items this will be gone
um
it will just remove uh junk basically
the the crap that makes windows run
slower after a while you can check and
uncheck certain things and that's like
an advanced thing so i won't check it
because i like my autocomplete
um
it'll take away cookies it'll take away
you download history internet history
cachet
saved information etc as well as
recently used
applications
this is for the cleaner part so i'm
going to hit analyze
if you don't want to analyze it before
you run it just hit run cleaner so it
says you can remove four megabytes not a
big deal but i will run it anyway it
says they have been removed now
very quick actually very very quick i
don't have that fast computer it's a
laptop
secondly there's a registry change i
have not run this in a while but
i will
i'll leave all these checked will
basically look in your registry find
unused shortcuts errors
issues missing dlls
uh installers that are no longer needed
and
delete slash fix so i have a few unused
file extensions dotpro.xpi i don't know
i don't even use those
so
it's just about finishing
and it only found four issues i'm gonna
hit fix selected issues and not backup
changes um
fix all selected issues
and then they're gone
done
tools
um you can uninstall programs
here's a list of all your programs
instead of going actually into the
control panel
waiting for that to load because you
know vista takes
ages and then
finding programs and features and
everything
it's right here it's right here for you
you can rename it uninstall it or just
delete it
completely and also you can remove
startup items so i have a few enabled
and if you disabled
you can select one and disable or delete
it completely
all in ccleaner and a few other options
here that i
don't really make much of a difference
you can run it when the computer starts
when it's just down
add it
so
pretty cool
that
ladies and gentlemen is ccleaner
have fun
you